foreign
[Music]
this week we bring you some exciting
updates in our news video whether it's
the upcoming Five Nights at Freddy's
movie the latest news from The Avengers
or a bunch of info about Planet of the
Apes four this video is sure to please
every movie buff
in 2025 Disney is going to release two
Avengers movies the Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars for the latter the
responsible parties have announced the
signing of the relevant screenwriter
this week and he is no stranger to the
MCU the talk is a Michael Waldron who is
in charge of writing the Loki series and
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness so he's actually a perfect
choice for the sixth Avengers movie
after all he kicked off the Multiverse
Saga by introducing the MCU series about
Thor's adoptive brother while also
teasing the new super villain Kang the
Conqueror for the film's predecessors
Avengers the Kang Dynasty Shang Chi and
the legend of the ten Rings Creator
Destin Daniel [ __ ] has already been
confirmed as director for the sequel
however this occupation is still unclear
the task is likely to be challenging
either way since it will most likely
Follow The Secret Wars comics closely
there the different universes of the
Marvel franchise Collide and there are
many different Heroes Have To Face Off
against each other in the meantime the
villain Dr Doom will take charge and
make life extremely difficult for the
superheroes Disney is unlikely to be in
a big hurry after the screenwriter
signing after all Avengers secret War
won't be released for another three
years on November 7th 2025.
the people responsible for the upcoming
Planet of the Apes four remained quiet
for a long time and in the meantime
there was even the impression that the
movie could be put on hold now after the
news about the allegedly very impressive
script a few weeks ago the production
seems to be finally moving forward again
not only did 20th century Studios
announce the official title Kingdom of
the Planet of the Apes they also
released a first image in a short
description of the cast the film marks
the beginning of a new saga that takes
place a few years after War for the
Planet of the Apes in the image you can
see an ape riding a horse in a
post-apocalyptic World nature seems to
have fought its way back as it covers
the gigantic skyscrapers and causes
waterfalls to form where there used to
be roads at first glance the scenery
even reminds us a little of the last of
us where the series of the same name is
supposed to be released in the near
future on the acting team two young
Stars Owen Teague and Freya Allen have
been cast while Teague is known from it
and this year's horror film gone in the
night 21 year old Alan has become famous
as geralt's adopted daughter Siri in The
Witcher series it is being speculated
that Teague will take on the role of
Caesar's son Cornelius while Freya Allen
could play a human part probably that of
the adult Nova anticipation is high
after Insider's claim to have discovered
that the screenplay is expected to be a
very pleasant surprise we are looking
forward to the film which will be
directed by West ball an exact release
date has not been set yet but the movie
is expected to hit theaters in 2024.
Dune was a real highlight of recent
science fiction film history the
adaptation of Frank Herbert's series of
novels of the same name will get the
appropriate sequel next year on November
17th however not only a cinematic sequel
is in the pipeline legendary television
is also working on the HBO series Dune
The Sisterhood and as deadline reports
there are first updates on the two
leading actresses British Chernobyl
actress Emily Watson is joining the cast
along with Shirley Henderson who made an
appearance in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire for instance the series
is to be set ten thousand years before
the events of the movie series and will
focus on the two sisters valya and Tula
they are part of the harkonen and they
later found a Sisterhood that eventually
develops into the Betty genocera who are
important in the films and books
strictly speaking the series is not
based on the series of novels by Frank
Herbert either but on the 2012 work
Sisterhood of Dune by Kevin J Anderson
and Brian Herbert the son one of the
Doom Creator in fact the series has been
in the planning stages for several years
but never got past the early production
time for a long time the first two
episodes will be directed by Chernobyl
director Johan rank when exactly the
series will debut on HBO is currently
unknown but we will keep you posted
in December of 2020 Marvel announced an
upcoming armor War series as part of the
MCU September 2022 was announced as the
kickoff date however the production went
differently from what was expected as
announced a couple of days ago Disney
has now completely dropped the series
from its lineup As Told By The Hollywood
Reporter the responsible parties had
decided on a serious change of plans for
armor Wars as a result the project will
now be redeveloped as a feature film
instead of a series the decision was
taken while working on the story which
is apparently better told in a feature
film also there is no longer any talk of
a September 2022 releasing instead the
as yet Untitled movie will now be
released on February 14
2025. so far the cast consists of Don
Cheadle as the main character Colonel
James Rhodes Alias War Machine while
making history star Yasir Lester is
still working on the script it is
completely known who will fill the
position of director but the search for
one will certainly keep going at full
speed what are your thoughts on the idea
of telling the story in a movie as
opposed to a series which format would
you like more for the MCU project feel
free to let us know your opinion in the
comments
Kiana Reeves is without a doubt one of
the biggest stars in Hollywood above all
thanks to his role as John Wick in the
film series of the same name he has been
able to inspire an audience of millions
in recent years that the 58 year old has
also mastered the art of film directing
is something he might prove in his
upcoming project Berserker it is said
that the Matrix actor is highly
interested in the director's job this
would certainly not be a crazy idea
since Reeves is also one of the creators
of the comic series Berserker which was
developed in collaboration with Matt
Kent and Ron Garney the story is about
the demigod bee who has been doomed to
live a life full of violence as an
immortal Warrior for thousands of years
this really stresses out the main
character so he decides to do some good
and is recruited by the US government as
a capable fighter in addition he has
promised that after all these years he
will finally find out what exactly his
fate is all about the script by mats and
Tom one has been finalized in the
meantime and so the shooting is not too
far away either that's precisely why the
question of the director's occupation
comes up most recently Reeve stated in
an interview with collider that there
was a 33 chance he himself would take on
both the directing duties and the lead
role before making this important
decision however he would need to read
the script first as he emphasized in the
interview could this mean that there are
already two other promising candidates
on the short list no personal matters
have yet been confirmed by those behind
the project so it is entirely possible
that Reeves himself will be the director
the John Wick actor made his first
attempt at directing in 2013 with the
film Man of Tai Chi but the reactions
were rather muted we will have to wait a
bit longer for more reliable information
but we do expect an announcement before
the end of the year
Five Nights at Freddy's originally
debuted eight years ago as a simple
point-and-click game from the horror
genre in several episodes you uncover
the creepy story of the animatronics
these are animal-like figures that you
often see in amusement parks and that
you can usually control remotely these
haunt the protagonist in The Game and
turn a night shift into a nightmare it
has been known for a while now that
there are plans to adapt the very
popular game to the big screen the good
news about the commitment of a director
was brought by horror Legend Jason Bloom
the owner of Bloom House Productions the
horror flick will be directed by Emma
Tammy who has already directed movies
such as the wind and into the dark blood
moon in close cooperation with Five
Nights at Freddy's Creator Scott cawthon
and Jason bloom a proper horror film is
now to be made by the way the
animatronics will be designed by Jim
Henson's Creature Shop the creator of
the famous Muppets among others it will
be exciting to see how closely the movie
will be based on the games of which the
last one was released in 2021 shooting
is scheduled to start in February of
2023 though details regarding the plot
have not been leaked yet in theory the
movie could either be inspired by one of
the numerous games or take its own
approach with the animatronics in any
case we are eagerly awaiting the outcome
all right now you're up to date in case
you're looking for more Marvel content
we highly recommend our new original for
Captain America 4 New World Order of
course the new trailer for Black Panther
2 wakanda forever is even more
action-packed and you can find that here
on our Channel as well so have fun
watching
laughs
[Music]